we got to get into loose for a little
bit okay
um I mean what a huge success and like a
huge fan base like I remember watching
that it was Netflix when Netflix took
over first of all how rare is it for a
show to where fox said they didn't want
to go on and yet they found a home at
Netflix that that just doesn't happen
usually a show's over it's over well
we'll take the five seasons and we'll
error those and they wanted another
season out of it right well we've done
by that point we've done three Seasons
just three yeah we've done and the first
season was like what they call like a
half season so it was 13 episodes and
then we did two of the full you know 22
episode biggies and then they cancelled
it how how did you feel by the way when
that happened oh I honestly I was gutted
I was I was I was at a fan convention in
Rome having the time of my life and like
having you know spent a whole weekend of
people just confessing their love for
the show and like talking about the show
and blah blah blah it you know I was
thousands of miles from where we'd film
this thing thinking my goodness isn't it
strange that we'd like we've got this
fan base is growing and growing and
growing and growing and then literally I
was in the mini buus on the way back
from the convention to the hotel we were
staying at and I got a call from our
showrunner saying that fox had just
canceled the
show uh and I just I was crushed I like
I was so like I was thrown I just didn't
I I didn't expect it to happen and I was
I was yeah I was pretty devastated I'm
not going to lie did you have to do a
Q&A after that no that was I so I just
done I think I just done my last day uh
thank God I know how are you keep it
straight for like yeah I hope it goes
forever too I know well the whole
weekend have been about people going
when are we going to hear about season 4
and I was like very soon very soon don't
worry and then I got the call and it was
like oh my god um but how long after did
you get the call saying hey they're
trying to get this going the weird thing
so I I traveled back to London uh from
Rome and I was just you know gutted and
I was talking to people on the phone and
whatever and then I found out that that
that was on like the Monday or Tuesday
and I found out that fox still hadn't
announced that they were had canceled it
yet um so we knew but no one else knew
and then uh then someone tipped me off
I'm not going to say who but someone
tipped me off that had planned to kind
of bury the news of the cancellation by
announcing something else at the same
time uh that following weekend Oh or
there new show replacing Lucifer and any
yeah yeah all of that and I was you know
I had a lot of emotion going on a lot of
these things and I decided that I would
take it upon myself to tweet that I had
found out the show had been cancelled
and I was absolutely gutted and I'm
sorry to everyone and I did that move I
did that before F anoun before the
announcement were they pissed I don't
care yeah I mean to be honest
with you at the time they fired you you
know what I I pressed send on that tweet
and then I had a panic attack cuz I
thought oh my god I've just like ruined
everything and blah blah blah right uh
and I I left my phone and I went uh into
my room and I was just like what have I
done uh blah blah blah and then I got my
together and about an hour and a
half later I went back to my phone and I
looked at it and it had absolutely blown
up but it had blown up in the most
positive way possible and this kind of I
I've said it before there's like tsunami
of love just came from around the world
from all these people hundreds of
thousands it was crazy and it didn't
stop that was the thing about it it just
snowboard and snowboard and snowboard
and snowboard and uh eventually I got a
call later that weekend from a guy
called Peter Roth who was had of Warner
Brothers TV who Warner Brothers was our
studio and they made it for
Fox um and he said Tom um like I want
you to know we're not ignoring all this
kind of all this stuff that's happening
on on social media um we are going to
try and do something about it um and so
I said what do you need me to do and he
said uh can you get over here to La um
you know just to keep keep it kind of
keep stoking the fire as it was so I got
on I I I got myself to Heath airport and
then I got to Heath airport I had a a
message from BBC News night now if
anyone knows that's big the UK there's
the news and then BBC News night is a
night is a nightly show that discusses
the news in a very very kind of like
intellectual you know articulate way 60
minutes yeah basically and they said
that they had noticed that they had been
you know noticing what was happening on
social media and blah blah blah about
the show did I want to appear as a guest
on the show to talk about that and to
talk about television changing and all
these things and I was like absolutely
so I got to LA and then I ended up doing
like a a studio bit back to London about
this and for the next kind of week and a
half two weeks it just like this became
like all I talked about and all people
were asking me about um and then you
know a couple weeks later I I'd sort of
been tipped off from Peter that that
things were progressing well and then we
got the Netflix announcement
and it was the most vindicating
wonderful
experience and I didn't feel quite so
bad to press about pressing send on that
tweet you single-handedly did that you
single-handedly brought back the show I
no I mean the the the crazy thing is
that I I'd already I already knew from
like three years of doing press for the
show that it really kind of started to
spread that people were loving this show
and not just in in the States but like
everywhere I was going to and weirdly
now when I look back at it lots of
Catholic countries all the countries
around the world that are Catholic are
really into the show don't know why but
there we go right um but um well they're
fascinated by that kind they are yeah
they're fascinated by that character and
you know you know what the their
perception of the devil is and what ours
was and but it was it was when I heard
it it been cancelled I thought oh
there's a lot of people who aren't going
to be very happy about this what I
didn't realize that there was millions
of people that were not happy about it
and wouldn't let it go